32e de finale face aux amateurs de
capelongue ça devrait pas poser trop de
problèmes il ya quand même un lourd
passé il ya dix sept ans les deux clubs
s'étaient rencontrés et qui était
l'attaquant vedette de capelongue à
l'époque samuel laurie est un problème
dans ce village
oh les gars on se recentre un peu là en
face c'est le match de leur vie
donc je veux te l'action aux concurrents
partira pas d'ici sortes de gens
où
est-ce quelque chose n'a pas nommé
[Musique]
j'aimerais me vois tu que j'ai
l'impression web a vu l'arbitrage
fallait s'y attendre
je sais que ces bordels tam echo cela
mais qu'est ce qu'ils veulent on leur a
rien fait nous c'est juste du foot je
sais pas perso [ __ ] c'est la merde
go go go go go
c'est maintenant que tout se jouera
tous nos efforts c'est aujourd'hui
qu'ils vont payer pour récupérer du cash
centimètre après centimètre et c'est
tous ensemble qu'on va y arriver
le
ensemble on est tous
seul n'est rien par merde [ __ ] que
puisque c'est ça le foot c'est la vie
c'est l'union
c'est le collectif